if superheroes are great on their own
then mashing up two different
superheroes to create a weird new
character
should be even better right well that's
not always the case the long history of
marvel comics creating mashup characters
has produced some classics but we've
seen plenty of bad ones too
best weapon h the incredible hulk and
wolverine
circled each other for years in a long
bloody rivalry with wolverine's
unbreakable bones and adamantium claws
matched up against hulk's indomitable
strength with both sporting healing
factors that rendered them
nearly impossible to kill put all of
that together and you get
marvel's ultimate weapon weapon h was
the product of the infamous weapon x
program responsible for the creation of
wolverine and deadpool among others
this time they stole dna from the
totally awesome hulk and
old man logan to create an utterly
unbeatable weapon
and they succeeded the idea of a hulk
foreign might sound like an
unimaginative marketing ploy but weapon
h was at the center of a compelling
action-packed and suspenseful story
unsurprisingly for anyone who read
weapons of mutant destruction marvel
greenlit the ongoing monthly weapon h
not long after the event's conclusion
worst
captain punisher civil war changed the
marvel universe drastically
and one of its darkest moments brought
the assassination of
captain america in the aftermath the
punisher decided
he would take the job in punisher war
journal number seven while investigating
a violent white supremacist group frank
castle donned a new red
white blue and black costume that
combined cap's look
and his own signature skulls castle's
apparent admiration for the late captain
didn't inspire punisher to change his
methods though
and he wasn't nearly as successful in
the role as steve rogers captain
punisher only lasted
four issues and never felt like it was
meant to last much longer if his
ill-fated adventure
hadn't been enough of a sign that he
should hang up the stars and stripes a
confrontation with bucky barnes who
actually would become the new captain
america was enough to make frank decide
that being a star-spangled avenger
just wasn't for him best storm goddess
of thunder
during a time when storm of the x-men
had lost all of her weather controlling
powers
she found herself in asgard where loki
tempted her with the gift of what seemed
to be the power of thor
when the new mutants and x-men arrived
loki's magic
clouded her senses making her see them
all as villains
at the story's climax loki unveiled a
hammer called stormcaster that he
crafted for storm which allowed her to
nearly kill wolverine with its magic
and even give the death goddess heller a
run for her money
eventually storm was able to see through
the illusions relinquishing the
thundering power
rather than keeping it and becoming
loki's porn that wasn't the last
appearance of this version of storm
though
recent issues revealed a glimpse of
storm in the future
once again becoming an asgardian goddess
of thunder
worst wendy hulk when jeff loeb and ed
mcguinness took over the hulk's title in
2008 they kicked things off by giving
the world one popular
alternate version of the green goliath
the red hulk eight issues later
readers got a brief look at a version of
bruce banner who was nowhere near as
compelling
the wendy hulk finding himself in a
tussle with not just one wendigo but a
whole army of them
the green hulk was transformed into a
giant green clawed
fangden furry monster who did little
more than
look gnarly and yell wendy hulk a lot
brother voodoo appeared out of nowhere
literally
cured him and that was that best
spider gwen gwen stacy's tragic demise
might be the most famous and
long-standing deaths in superhero comic
history but on another earth gwen
never died instead it was her not peter
parker who received a fateful bite from
a radioactive spider and used the
resulting powers to fight crime
as spider woman spider gwen was
introduced in edge of spider verse and
she was an immediate hit with readers
emerging from the event with her own
monthly title
she's since become a fixture at marvel
appearing in cartoons and video games
and she's one of the characters set to
appear in the upcoming spider-man into
the spider-verse movie she's more than
just a cool spin-off with a killer
costume design though the death of the
main continuity's gwen stacy in 1973
is generally seen as one of the more
important moments in superhero comics
but it also made her one of the earliest
female comic book characters to be
killed
just to further a male protagonist's
plotline that spider gwen became a
breakout
character shows that superheroes are
moving in the right direction without
removing the tragedy
of the original story worst the teenage
hulk
in the late 70s marvel started
publishing
what if giving readers alternate
versions of classic stories
in its 12th issue we get the story of
what would happen if bruce banner didn't
get caught in a gamma blast while trying
to save a teenager
named rick jones instead it was rick
himself who got belted with gamma rays
the teenage hulk what if number 12 was
hilarious
like the original rick jones he spouted
dialogue that definitely
feels like it was written by adults who
were trying and
failing to reproduce the cool slang of
the youth
he called bruce banner a square granted
that the soldiers hunting him down
armed with shifts and heaters were
uncool
before deciding to split or cut out
when he agreed to join the avengers it
was because hulk
digs it when he battled annihilus in the
negative zone
he urged the villain don't jive hulk the
rick jones of the regular marvel
universe would actually become the hulk
for a short period but never enjoyed
this kind of wonderful dialogue best
franken castle there are a lot of marvel
mashups that were created in the pages
of
what if or other weird timelines so if
you saw the words
franken castle and thought it was the
product of an alternate reality that's
understandable the truth however
is that this one is a hundred percent
canon
after helping to thwart an alien
invasion by shooting the scroll queen
norman osborne better known to
spider-man fans as the green goblin was
named the head of homeland security
this did not sit well with the punisher
but his attempt at assassinating osborne
didn't go as planned
instead on osborne's orders the punisher
himself was killed by wolverine's son
dawkin who literally chopped frank into
pieces and threw him in the sewer the
thing
is frank didn't die instead the punisher
awoke to find himself pieced together by
the vampire morbius who recruited him to
protect an
underground city of monsters with his
corpse stitched up
and reanimated by a mystical artifact
called the bloodstone
he was re-christened as frankencastle
and stayed that way for an entire year
eventually the bloodstone's magic
regenerated his human body but
it remains the punisher's most bizarre
adventure ever
even weirder than the time he was a
ghost who killed angels with magic guns
worst he smeared superheroes
aren't the only ones who get mashed up
but in the case of piecemeal
maybe it would have been better if they
were shortly after its explosive 400th
issue
incredible hulk teased its readers by
revealing small glimpses of a new
and seemingly unstoppable villain
finally peacemail struck in incredible
hulk
number 407 and didn't quite live up to
the hive piecemeal had the power to
absorb and reproduce the abilities and
appearance
of superpowered people and in his first
appearance
he looked to have the cybernetic arms of
silverman the clawed hands of sabretooth
the face of the red skull
the chest piece of atuma and the facial
hair of
abraham lincoln maybe even with the
mighty beard of our 16th
president piecemeal failed to be much of
a threat to the hulk
after months of build up he was speared
through the torso and tossed into loch
ness
which was the last anyone ever saw of
him best
cosmic ghost writer most mashup
characters stop
after combining two heroes but thanos
number 13
introduced the world to cosmic ghost
rider a full-on combo meal of the
punisher
ghost rider silver surfer and maybe even
deadpool
after the last of earth's superheroes
fell at thanos's hand
a dying frank castle aka the punisher
made a deal with the demonic mephisto
marvel's devilish villain cursed him
with the power of the ghost rider
a demonic force tasked with punishing
the guilty
with no one left on earth though castle
went insane and when galactus journeyed
to earth
looking for allies against thanos this
new ghost rider offered to become his
new herald
gaining the cosmic power of the silver
surfer
of course thanos eventually killed
galactus but he
and cosmic ghost rider found themselves
unable to kill each other and eventually
teamed up as marvel's oddest possible
version of
the odd couple worst d-man
d-man aka demolition man isn't really a
marvel mash-up he's just a guy
with a really bad costume dennis dunphy
was introduced as a wrestler who was
part of the unlimited class
wrestling federation a wrestling
organization for people with superhuman
physical attributes
he was a star in the ring with the
enhanced strength he received by
using an addictive drug peddled by the
power broker
eventually dunphy left the ucwf to help
captain america
take the broker down and designed the
costume he's most known for a mask made
to look like wolverines
and the rest of the outfit based on
daredevil's original red
and yellow suit d-man has since become
little more than a joke in marvel comics
a character so minor and so unloved he
regularly goes through traumatic changes
including dying only to show up the next
time without anyone explaining
how he got better